welcome to this video legend legend 2014
that's a new opponent probably a new
account VI a brand new account but he
has pretty high ratings can trying the
Trump option Trump escapes is the right
pronunciation the Trump again i really
liked what i got from this opening the
positions okay this is more like a
benoni here and he played a really early
night BTW satnam i'm trying to play this
very aggressively with f45 is maybe too
much even ok so just trying to complete
development here Bishop d3 and castles
what he wants to do is play c4 in this
position after castles ok I can go to
eat too though it's not not so terrible
no it is not place your for interesting
I mean be five I just play a 4 and this
is really really wrong ok you just he
does it anyway ah ok ok ok takes in a be
for naught b1 you can play see form
immediately this might be the idea
otherwise Knight B 1 D to C 4 would be
excellent for wide okay well a 4 is
still the right the right moves I mean
no matter the the the evaluation have to
have to play it I think now see form if
I get in 92 to c4
and then something has gone wrong c4
takes Knight takes form for world
complications okay that's strange really
i thought that was was even quite good
for black okay so 94-96 it's not not
that great I can also play C for just to
totally support everything maybe takes
politics i still have c4 later to get
this complete points and the a5 was an
interesting alternative intending night
c4 but after a five a thought you might
play is six now he's playing that okay
so Bishop takes Knight takes Knight
takes Knight takes okay and so I have to
retreat as c4 was interesting
interesting as in good I mean it looked
like a good move so do i switch over
with the Queen somehow to h4 is this is
this not on this is probably probably
also a move activating
yeah okay the c-4 idea probably wasn't
the best idea ever from my for my part I
mean as he he got in see for himself
this means that it is really failed know
he's got relatively active pieces I
think he six now looks very logical
rook takes a play I wrote checks
nonsense f F five years f5 but I'm
really really in the wrong diagonal here
what about Quinn age three is not good
yeah come on let's let's put this piece
into play at least he cannot easily play
a five as it's hanging on f6 okay so
much for he cannot easily play that
maybe he can you should f6 and rook a
fade or something still looks terribly
weird to allow it okay I'm taking I
thought work a fade
okay no I can take with the Queen I can
take with the pawn pawn rook takes and
Knight takes e4 is really possible right
so probably Queen takes i also have
Queen takes e4 check now check as an
additional possibility so we cannot
easily take care due to the pin I want
to activate the Knight to g5 is the best
possible square but if he allows me to
do that for Farooq f7
yes how do I do this now it really looks
kind of dangerous so I age 16
I don't know I have to play for Queen
age form
h6 rook f6 yes as a synthesis rather
rather dangerous let's to put it very
mildly and takes root cakes king of
seven I don't see a chick made and she
ate also not made funny this is kind of
a defense yes time warning
all right to play move takes Queen oh no
I can't I can't take with the night you
can take or way drop just rope g6 look
f6 Kim G seven check this is no mate is
this is this really true check check g8
ah don't tell me there's no checkmate
here there is no maid yes unbelievable
stuff there is no made here unbelievable
that I screwed this up
come on air this is frustrating from
this position yeah not to win this is
really tough but I'm energem check check
check ah white resins sure to check
points for for absolutely nothing and
the winning attack yet and still you
draw it's not so easy look at 60 takes
takes takes it wins you're up to six
wins but why do i do I don't let's see I
mean check check so this I didn't see
how I'm winning here chad is this check
this is winning yeah because I get
absolutely everything yes check and the
end the night at the end well yeah they
must it was clear that there's a win I
mean how lost do you want to do you want
to be a I saw that this is not where but
I didn't see a win yes this is just
embarrassing check and of course I could
have done some some easier stuff
probably what else is there there's
something else that wins chess is made
this is a made extra check check check
check check check check mate yeah it's
okay I mean it it's a little bit deep
yeah but you you see that he sees his
somehow he should get checkmated but
it's it's still not so easy with 40
seconds
something I mean though okay let's just
start a new game thanks for watching